cuántos centilitros hay en un de cali
tro para responder esta pregunta debemos
entender a qué se refiere el prefijo
cnri y el prefijo de acá para saber cómo
son estas unidades con respecto a los
litros bueno déjame escribir una lista
de prefijos que son muy útiles para
resolver problemas del sistema métrico
el primero que voy a poner es kilo kilo
kilo
estaba un poco más a cada kilo se
refiere a mil a mil luego aquí voy a
poner ésta
que está bien esto no voy a poner así
esto esto se refiere a siendo luego
viene de acá de acá que quiere decir 10
si no tenemos prefijo eso quiere decir 1
y luego vienen los prefijos para hacer
las cosas más pequeñas que serían de sí
de sí que se refiere a una décima parte
sentí
sentí que es una centésima parte o sea 1
/ 100
y finalmente viene mil y mil que es para
cuando queremos uno entre mil de algo
uno entre mil muy bien vamos a utilizar
estos prefijos en el problema primero
nos hablan acerca de centilitros lo voy
a poner en color rosa aquí al lado
entonces que nos dice este prefijo nos
dice que un centilitro un centilitro
litro es igual a 1 entre 100 litros uno
entre 100 litros
litros otra forma de escribir esto es
que en cada litro hay 100 centilitros lo
voy a poner así en cada litro en un
litro
hay 100
centilitros sentí litros
trozos muy bien eso es para centilitros
ahora vamos a de k litros que lo voy a
hacer en color verde el prefijo de k
quiere decir 10 entonces eso nos dice
que un deck a litro un deck a litro de k
es lo mismo que 10 litros 10 litros de
esta forma podemos ponerlo también así
podemos ponerlo como que cada 10 litros
cada 10 litros es lo mismo que un de acá
litro de acá de acá litro
pero muy bien con esto ya entendemos que
es un deck a litro y un centilitro antes
de responder el problema pensemos un
poquito que tenemos nos piden pasar
centilitros adeca litros o más bien
queremos saber cuántos centilitros hay
en un de cali tro o sea queremos pasar
más bien al revés de lo que dije verdad
de carlitos a centilitros y entonces eso
nos daría mucho sentí litros pues sí
porque de k litro es una unidad más
grande que sentí litro entonces un deck
a litro son varios entre centilitros
sale bueno ahora sí vamos a resolver el
problema hay dos formas de hacerlo ya
que tenemos esta tabla podemos
aprovecharla para ir pasando de unidad
en unidad o bien podemos utilizar un
análisis dimensional asegurándonos
obtener las unidades correctas vamos a
realizar lo de las dos formas primero
utilicemos la tabla imagínate que
tenemos un deck a litro si tenemos un
deck a litro eso quiere decir que
tenemos 10 litros entonces tenemos 10
litros sale
a 10 litros cuántos decilitro sería qué
pasa si avanzamos al siguiente renglón
bueno pues un decilitro es una décima
parte de un litro de modo que en un
litro son diez decilitros como tenemos
diez litros hay que multiplicar diez por
diez así que nos quedaría 100 indec a
litros son 100 decilitros y podemos
hacer lo mismo para pasar al siguiente
renglón tenemos que que 10 centilitros
son un decilitro entonces 100 decilitro
son 1000 mil centilitros y de esta forma
un deck a litro son 1000 centilitros eso
ya responde la pregunta la respuesta
sería que hay 1000 mil centilitros se en
ti
sentí litros bueno esa es una forma de
hacerlo utilizando la tabla pero también
podemos hacerlo con un análisis
dimensional o vaya utilizando estas
conversiones como se le haría para
hacerlo así
bueno pues déjame empezar otra vez con
un deck a litro lo voy a poner en color
amarillo un deck a litro de cada litro
y lo que vamos a hacer es primero
pasarlo a litros y luego vamos a pasar
litros a centilitros entonces un deck a
litro lo tendría que multiplicar por
haber pues me gustaría que la unidad de
cal y tros eliminar así que aquí voy a
poner de cada litro
de k litro y me gustaría que apareciera
litros o litros entonces aquí le pongo
litro pero tenemos que utilizar este
factor de conversión verdad tenemos que
ponerle aquí que hay 10 litros en cada
de acá litro realizando la
multiplicación de cali tro se cancela
con el de cada litro y esto es igual a
10 litros 10
y otros y ahora hay que pasar estos
litros a centilitros para lo cual vamos
a utilizar esta conversión déjame
utilizar el color rosa a lo mejor aquí
debí haber usado verde pero bueno déjame
utilizar ahora esta conversión ahora una
vez más tenemos litros y queremos que se
cancelen entonces vamos a ponerlos en el
denominador aquí vamos a ponerle litros
y en el numerador queremos que aparezcan
sentí litros
ti
y otros muy bien entonces qué tenemos
que hacer
bueno pues poner que hay 100 100
centilitros en cada litro y te das
cuenta esto dice la misma información
que esto porque simplemente son
recíprocos bueno el litro se cancela con
litros nos queda 10% es decir nos queda
mil mil
sentí sentí litros centilitros y esta
sería la segunda forma de responder el
problema todo esto tiene mucho sentido
da lo mismo que la otra forma y además
concuerda con lo que platicamos acerca
de que tenían que aparecer varios
centilitros por cada de cada litro